everyone and welcome this is a very odd
position in which to speak but anyway
thank you all for being here it's almost
the end of two incredibly busy days I
know my brain is totally about to blow
up but I'm very grateful you came to my
presentation it's a talk that I wanted
to give for very long time and then
turns out that this is literally the
only venue that will accept a talk about
how things work inside Kafka so here we
are
it's I wanted to share that because
Kafka is even more useful than using and
there is a poorly documented but really
nice general-purpose protocol inside of
Kafka's that I think will be awesome if
more people knew about and used so I'm
glad that you are all interested in
learning about it and maybe using it
just for a quick show of hands how many
of you know Kafka like if I say you have
topics and partitions and they produce
and consume good chunk of you okay so
I'll go pretty quickly about the parts
that what is Kafka and then start
driving into the details so bear with me
so we'll start with a very very brief
Kafka 101 and then we start talking
about the consumer protocol and what
were the requirements and why did we
designed it the way we did is three
different times by the way and then I'll
go into the implementation and like how
the protocol itself works and then I'll
go through three examples of how we use
this protocol for things that have
absolutely nothing to do or very little
to do with consumers so that's the idea
about me I'm not actually a small bird
but this is a book that I wrote I
currently work for a company called
confluent and since I had to say it a
lot the last two days we do not do
wiki's we are a company founded by the
people who invented Apache cough cough
for linkedin left with the company we
maintained Kafka we add new features we
say look Africa support we also have a
bunch of other stuff that should make it
easier for you to use kava and so let's
talk about come on
okay I think just since I'm stuck here
anyway by a bunch of barriers I may as
well just use a keyboard so what is
Kafka well the way we some time this is
ripe Kafka is a streaming platform
what is streaming platform means it
means that you take events you publish
them Khafre cons towards them as nicely
ordered streams of events you can
subscribe to those events and control
them and then we have things like
connectors that allows you to generate
those events from something like a
database or to send those events to
something like a database and we have
stream processing modules that lets you
read a stream do stuff to it and write a
new one a Kafka the capital cluster
itself at the core is a glorified a
storage mechanism we sometimes say that
it's a message queue that married the
file system so that's one way to look at
it at the very core of Kafka we have the
idea of partitions and sometimes we call
them logs there is a book I love logs
that explains that a log basically an
ordered set of stuff that happen is the
basic abstraction of most of data
management so if you have data bases
they can offer based on those redo logs
and Kafka takes it to be a first order
contract so if you publish events into a
topic they get stored into a bunch of
those partitions partitions the unit of
scalability of a topic so topic will
have a lot of partitions they will be
stored in all different kinds of servers
and you will produce and consume events
with those partitions and each one of
those partitions is well ordered
preserving order is the one job that
Kafka really tries hard to do very well
and there is sequence numbers also
called offsets to every message in a
partition now every partition is
replicated three times because it's a
distributed system and machines can go
poof and disappear on us and so the one
of the partitions is a leader and
basically always produce events to the
leader epic sorry not one of the
petitions one of the replicas of a
partition is a leader we produce events
to the leader replicas we consume events
from the leader replicas we do that
because that's the easiest way to
maintain consistency and remember that
consistency is the one thing that Kafka
tries to do really really well and then
the replicas live on separate brokers
and if something bad happens we count on
one of the other replicas the replicas
have one job remember the leader does
handles all produce and consumes the
replicas also they have to do is keep
copying events from the leader and try
to keep up where if something happens
with the leader we basically choose
another one of those replicas as the new
leader and starts producing and
consuming there and hope is that we did
not lose any message on the way and we
don't have to hope we have guarantees
that's a totally different talk now if
we look at how we consume events a
consumers basically starts reading
hopefully from the beginning of a topic
that they're interested in and they kind
of move forward continuing to read stuff
after a while they reach a state that
they're happy with and they store their
current position in what we call a
consumer offset topic so we the consumer
says okay I read up to event number
seven on partition zero and I've read up
to event number four in partition one
please keep it for me and then if
something happens with the consumer if
is a crash for example I need to figure
out where to start again I start from
the last sales to offset the whole
opposite management thing is incredibly
it looks simple it was actually pretty a
bit more sophisticated than that it's a
fascinating topic in its own right I'll
have a list of references at the end and
you can find a different presentation
that tells you all about of it now one
of the cool things about Kafka and
arguably the reason that it's really
took off in popularity is that you can
have really really really large number
of consumers and fifty thousand is not
unheard of and each one of them will
manage its own position in the queue so
there is they are totally independent
and unrelated to each other and look at
how little information you really need
in order to maintain a consumer this is
basically what allows Kafka to have a
lot of consumers while as a pubsub like
messaging systems try to keep a lot more
state and therefore have a lot more
issues in memory location as the number
of consumers grow now I made it sound
like there is just one consumer for all
the partitions at least for certain
topic this is a hundred percent
incorrect so if you have one consumer
and you start console and say I'm
interested in events from the clicks
topic you'll start getting all clicks
but at any reasonably sized website at
some point one consumer will not really
be able to handle all those clicks if
you add more consumers to the same
consumer group which you define with a
group ID it'll basically kind of figure
it out and say okay I'm reading those
partitions you are reading those other
partitions and just kind of balance
between them they will still commit
offsets to the exact same partition
because just imagine there is a Walden
which is a lot of consumer groups you
don't want to look through all the
states of every single consumer group in
Kafka in order to know what you're
supposed to read next so having a single
partition with everything that goes on
in the consumer group basically lets
everyone find its state relatively
easily now one of the things you get
with the consumer group is that if a
consumer crashes we detect that and the
other consumers can basically keep on
reading the same partitions and so you
have automated failover you don't get
all front partitions and these skills as
long as you have extra partitions and
then if you try to add more consumers
and you have partitions you'll have what
we sometimes call unemployed consumers
they have no partitions to read from all
this is very simple the rest of the
presentation will go into the
excruciating details of how this how
consumer groups really work how do we
discovers that a new consumer just
joined our group how do we decide who is
reading what how do we detect that
something went away and we need to
rebalance all those things are the topic
of this presentation note that
wrote this protocol basically three and
a half times we started with using
zookeeper zookeeper did not scale to the
number of consumer groups or the number
of consumers in the same group that we
wanted and we had a lot of trouble with
that we went and wrote a nice protocol
and then we decided that no it's
actually not good for a bunch of reasons
that I'm going to explain in a second
and then we wrote one we actually
implemented it we the number two we
discarded before we even started
implementation or at least shortly after
we saw the implementation but before it
was merged they may have been a branch
and then we did you know you have
something it goes live people start
using it immediately people started
complaining about certain properties
having to do with mark bits I'll talk
about it and then we basically you know
you kind of ignore all the complaints
and say people are stupid you don't know
you don't understand us for like six
months and then after six months it's
like okay I don't know if people are
stupid or my protocol is stupid but I
have to fix it because I can no longer
take the complaints basically so here we
are so what the requirements that we had
when we started designing this protocol
basically immediately after we said that
okay no more zookeeper for managing
consumer groups the first is like the
basics right if there's one job for
consumer group is that you have to
allocate partitions when new consumers
join the group and you have to allocate
consumers when something goes wrong and
someone either fails or leaves the group
so the allocation of partitions to
consumers in a dynamic way is the one
things that we knew we absolutely have
to do and then the second thing was the
part that was actually a bit
controversial we decided that the
partition assignment has to be done by
the clients themselves not by the
brokers why is that because the first
the second design after zookeeper was
basically let's have a broker make the
decision and then when we thought about
it a bit more we're like well first of
all we don't think it should be the
broker because that means that if a sort
of an amazing new way to distribute
partitions that works really well with
my application I
to really be able to use it until I
convinced someone to upgrade my broker
or configure something on my broker or
install something on the broker very
often it's two totally different teams
on organization getting stuff done
between those teams proved to be a much
harder problem than we ever anticipated
basically the hardest problem computer
science is getting two teams at the same
company to work together 100% so we
decided to totally by step that by
giving control to the clients and then
the concern was do the clients know
enough to make a good decision or do we
need the centralized control just to
enforce good decisions and it turns out
that the brokers don't really know
anything that the clients don't already
know actually any attempt to enforce
rules by the broker hand up restricting
the clients for example the first
attempt was oh the brokers only will
know if two clients are trying to
consume the same partition and we need
to prevent that but know who says you
have to prevent that maybe my
application really wants to have some
kind of standby and I want two clients
to consume the same partition so the
brokers basically don't know anything
that I don't know in the clients at
least in the clients collectively when
and therefore the brokers are not
qualified to make a decision as they
should not stand on the way okay so
requirements one in Tour done and then
requirements real for basically came
from very large users of Kafka
especially the LinkedIn team as I said
look we have to support somewhere to the
order of magnitude of 30,000 consumer
groups because that may or may not be
what we're currently running in
production and we have to support
consumer groups of the size of hundreds
of consumers in a single group why
because if you have a failover cafe
cluster and you have a brain weight and
it's really big and you have to copy
everything from one cover cluster to
another in real time you need a very
large consumer group to do it because
you're consuming every single partition
on your cafe cluster in a single group
so we needed to support those two things
no questions about it and then the last
one is obvious it has to be consistent
once the consumer once there is an
assignment you are reading this
partition you are reading the other
partition you cannot just let anyone do
whatever they want they have to comply
with the assignment
so what is the protocol really supposed
to support what are the operations well
you're supposed to be able to join the
group and then we wanted to elect a
leader and have it assigned resources
later is any one of those clients and we
wanted the consumers to have to maintain
membership that's how we detect if
something goes wrong and willing to
reallocate as if failed to maintain
membership and then you want to allow
them somehow to leave the group nicely
so we wouldn't have to wait for them to
just not ping us often enough and so
this is basically all the activities
that I'll go over how we do and the way
it works and I'm saying this now so it
would be a bit easier for you to follow
the protocol we ended up with a three
layer protocol or at least two layer and
then one of them is kind of split the
basic protocol the ones that I'll start
talking about is the Kafka group
membership protocol it's responsible for
who is a member in this group and who is
a leader and then there is the group
protocol itself it's the protocol that
members of the client consumer group
used to basically decide on a location
how do they communicate with each other
how do remember I said that all the
information exists on the client but it
exists on the clients in a collective
way if you need to know what if but we
needed the leader who makes the decision
to have all this collective information
you need a language for that and this is
the group protocol and then inside that
there is a sub protocol which is the
only part that is actually called the
protocol I think and this is basically
the assignment algorithm like how do we
assign partitions and some extra
metadata that may assist in that so
we'll talk through all that and I'll
point out an occasion which layer I'm
talking about so how are you using the
protocol today there is the consumer
group membership and I start by talking
about how we do that because that's the
base use case and then we use it on
three other places kafir Connect uses
the same protocol to basically take data
copying tasks and assign them to
different workers caf-co streams uses it
to assign partitions to tasks to
specific host at a specific state and
schema registry uses it for leader
election and I'm going those are the
three use cases I'm going to talk about
for years
I'll talk about in detail so for the
consumer group use-case who are we
talking about we are talking about
consumers who only the only thing they
want is to know which partitions to
start consuming and then on the broker
side we have coordinators and any broker
can be a connect coordinator every
broker is a coordinator for a specific
subset of the consumer groups but every
group only talks to a single coordinator
at any given time otherwise it would be
very hard for them to communicate so the
coordinator facilitates the
communication between the consumer
groups and therefore if we're a consumer
group the first thing we have to start
doing before we do anything else is find
our coordinator so luckily there is a
find coordinator request so all of kafka
protocol is basically a request response
protocol so I'm going to at every point
when I'm talking about the protocol
let's say what is the request and then
what is the response they find
coordinator request is the only request
in these protocols that can go to any
broker in the cluster everything else
will go to the coordinator and we
basically say hey I'm a member of group
X who is my coordinator and we had to
basically find a way that everyone who
asked this question will get absolutely
the same answer but also that it will
scale so if my head will move brokers
then I'll actually take that into
account what we ended up doing is
basically saying hey we already have
this common offsets topic it has a lot
of partitions so it's well distributed
it has replicas so a single replica will
always be alive for every one of those
partitions meaning that if I take the
group ID hash it divided by the new
module with the number of partitions in
the topic and I get a partition number
partition number 15 I find the leader
the leader will be a broker that is
alive this is the promise of a partition
leader I find a broker to talk to and
now I have a broker to talk to and I no
longer have to worry at all about
offsets so we use the same find
coordinate or protocol even for things
like schema registries that cares
nothing at all about of it it's just a
convenient convention
the thing you bet back is basically URL
host port and security protocol if it
exists of the broker you're supposed to
tape to talk to so here is your
coordinator go I found my coordinator
the next thing I not want to do is send
a joint group and now that's a lot of
information so I do a joint group the
first thing is that I'm joining Group X
right and then I have to send a memory
but I'm only now just joining the group
for the first time I don't have a member
ID so I'm sending an empty string I will
get a member ID back no worries and then
I want to say what protocol am I talking
in this is the secondary protocol the
one that determines what is the
resources that are actually getting
assigned so the resources that get
assigned our consumers to partitions so
this is the consumer protocol what
algorithm do I support for assigning
partitions this can be a list so let's
say that I'm interested in vendor sign
mint or load balance assignment or
sticky assignment so I specify one of
those and then we can specify metadata
the basic metadata that members of the
consumer protocol have to support our
day is what kind of topics and
partitions I'm interested in so hey I'm
a member of the group X and I want to
read topic T and range assignment is my
favorite assignment algorithm and
everyone sends the same information and
the coordinator takes this information
and responds to first of all if you are
the first consumer to join the group you
are now the leader of that group and we
keep the members of the group in a nice
little link list so the first one goes
away we know who the next one is and get
a new leader
note the of one leader election because
we have a single coordinator
coordinating the entire thing so we have
the members and so then when we know who
the leader is
he gets the list of all the other
members and all the metadata remember
the metadata is what topics are
interested in so you get member eggs is
in member one is interested in property
remember two is interested in
t/n topic t5 like you got just get all
of that and then everyone gets their own
member ID now I have a member ID for
everything else that I do you get a
protocol that we all decided that we are
going to use when I say protocol right
now I mean the arrange assignment
protocol and I'll talk about why we need
to send this back in a second the leader
I definitely have to know but everyone
else should know as well and then we
also tell everyone who is the leader
sometimes this is useful now about
electing de assignment process why this
is really important everyone can specify
a list of assignment possessors in an
order that they care about and this is
the way it works
so you basically everyone says hey I am
round-robin I want to read round-robin
and then you the coordinator basically
looks at all their protocols that
everyone talks in and says okay everyone
agrees that they want to do round-robin
so this is our candidate and because
it's the only candidate it gets all the
votes so everyone is going to talk Rand
Robin and the reason is useful and the
first one is so disinteresting I'm like
oh my god this is such over-engineering
when will I ever need that turns out to
be incredibly important in upgrades so
you basically say I prefer to talk to be
keep protocol because I have some
improvement that I know will happen if I
use the sticky protocol but if somebody
else insists on on Robin you know I
support it
we didn't delete the old code yet and
everyone else basically says the same
thing not the last one was not upgraded
yet so the last one does not support
sticky yet it will only support it after
another upgrade which means it's right
now the only languages everyone talks in
is round robin it's the only candidate
it gets all votes but now I finished my
upgrade I bounced the last consumer it's
doing a join group again and as you'll
see later it means that everyone else
has to do join group again and that
means that everyone now supports round
robin and sticky we have two candidates
for the first time ever well it's a
notice how everyone specified sticky
first it means that sticky is the
preferred protocol which means that
sticky now got a majority of the vote so
after everyone joins the
all the groups with this a preferences
now the protocol that gets elected is
sticky and we just did a successful
upgrade I'm pointing it out because
rumor has been that people don't
actually know how to switch between two
assignment assignments in the same
consumer group without taking everything
down at the same time now you know you
don't have to if you learn nothing else
useful from this presentation it's how
to switch to a new assignment protocol
so we got that and next thing now that
we all know who is the leader and what
protocol we're using it's time to sync
the group again and now we get the
assignment and the whole reason for the
to phase is to allow us to a select a
leader and be agree on a protocol so
that's the reason we actually have join
group and sing group as two separate
steps so sing group we basically send
again here is my group ID here is my
member ID everyone sent that if I am the
leader in between those two calls it was
my job to decide which consumer is
reading which partitions based on the
protocol so based on if it's supposed to
be sticky I try to keep whatever the
previously here if it's round-robin I do
you get one you get two you get three
you can for you at five bits it you get
a day if it's range okay you get one two
three you get four to six you get seven
to nine so you get the idea the leader
basically makes the assignment
coordinators towards the assignment in
Kafka it has two good things first if
the coordinator gets lost we did not
lose the assignment and the second it
means if you want to kind of peek around
and know what's going on in the money as
someone who monitors you can just check
in Kafka what's going on anyway after it
towards the assignment it basically
takes for each member it says okay
you're reading those partitions you're
reading those partitions you're reading
those partitions and that's about it
woohoo we have a working consumer group
consumers know what to consume they can
start consuming messages pretty much by
this point you have a working consumer
group you can see that this is two
round-trip so you don't want it to
happen all too often which means that we
need away from
consumers to tell us they're still alive
and keep hanging on to their existing
partitions enter their heartbeat and the
heartbeats are super simple
you basically say I'm still alive this
is the group this is my member ID don't
forget me and if every single
coordinator says everything is okay I'll
talk about every single knot okay in one
second now this is allows us to detect
like if we did not get a heartbeat in
say ten minutes we can say okay the
consumer is grown let's say rebalance
remember we don't want to rebalance
previously too often so we want to give
it a nice good interval on the other
hand what if someone actually wants to
live we don't want to take ten minutes
to decide if we he already knows that
he's going to live we want to
immediately rebalance and just shorten
the downtime in consuming a set of
partitions this is an interesting
trade-off on the other hand you don't
want to vote too often and on the other
hand you want to detect as soon as
possible if something went wrong so you
can continue consuming we have a bunch
of rebalance timeouts and heartbeat
timeouts and session timeout that you
can tune to your heart content and this
is not that presentation on how to tune
in to be honest it's not like you have
very clear answers anyway so if you want
to leave the group and not wait for the
whole detection thing you basically go
and say hey I am leaving the group and
coordinator says okay so now I have to
let everyone know and they have to
rebalance but it also responds to you
and say okay everything is good bye-bye
that's pretty much all it has to say
really okay so we are pretty much done
with how this whole consumer group
protocol works one more thing
rebalancing because this is an essential
concept here so when do we rebalance
when do we shuffle partitions around we
shuffle them when it's not really a
shuffle it's reassigning basically and
we realign when a member dies which
basically means that for a long time you
didn't heart beat all when you say I'm
leaving already new member joints all
wind topic metadata changes and you know
if you just go to Kafka and add ten
partitions to a topic
you want them someone to start consuming
those ten partitions so this will also
force every balance how do we discover
that we need to do it well remember
comers continuously poll they get data
they send the heartbeats as a commit
offset etc etc remember when I said that
the heartbeat can have responses other
than okay those are two responses can be
different than okay basically saying
sorry one response it's basically says
okay actually very important to tell you
rebalancing is going on right now
somebody already joined the group and we
are now waiting for everyone else to
rejoin so we can reassign and then
basically once you discover that you are
in the middle of every balance you
basically have one thing to do you have
to stop everything as you are doing stop
consuming stop fetching stop committing
offsets god don't commit offsets when
you know that you already lost the
partitions that you now have in someone
else maybe already on the way to start
processing them definitely a bad time to
commit offsets just stop everything
rejoin the group
sync again and get in your new
assignment now obviously all these
protocols that I described is described
in an interface so we have abstract
coordinator and there is the part that
it implements for you and the parts that
you have to implement if you decide to
override this coordinator if you the
example that I talked about is basically
absolute coordinator plus consumer
coordinator and this is all it's all
coordinator but it's really runs on the
client side the things that actually is
what I called coordinator the entire
time and runs on the broker side it's
called group coordinator which does not
inherit from abstract coordinator I hope
this was incredibly clear did not
confuse me at all even for a second and
so I want to write my own client that
participates in this coordination loop
and in order to do that I have to
implement an abstract coordinator and
the things I have to implement is
basically my protocol type which has be
unique I have to define my own metadata
in the case of consumer coordinator it
was the topics and partitions I may have
my own resource to assign I'll show you
a bunch of examples
and then I won't have to implement three
methods what to do before John usually
just clean up a lot of state what to do
how does what is an assignment look like
which is the things that the leader will
run between the join and the sink how do
I take this entire list of resources and
entire list of members and start
assigning one to each and that's the big
one that's the one I'll keep describing
over and over again and then what to do
when John completes which is normally
start working more or less so know that
you don't have to implement heartbeat it
looks the same to everyone you don't
have to implement live you don't have to
have to implement find coordinator you
could you know no I don't think any of
them are final but why okay
so let's use that and elect a leader
that's kind of a nice basic example and
for that we have a schema registry and
the schema registry basically has two
scheme registry is used to maintain
metadata for topics kind of thing you
don't really have to know what it is
it's opposed to operations you can read
a schema and you can do it from any
schema registry workers that you have
run all you can write a new schema and
in order to maintain consistency you
have to do it at a schema registry
leader and if you try to write a schema
to a non leader you get back no no you
talk to that leader and the way we did
when we implemented the protocol so our
protocol is called SR schema registry
and the resource we ensign now is no
longer a list of topics and partitions
we send in our identity basically this
is my URL hostel port and I'm eligible
or maybe not eligible to become a leader
and then the first thing that you do
after joining a group is that you get
back a leader so because that's what the
coordinator returns remember he telex
the leader so we have a leader are we
done yet no we are not done yet because
this is the leader that was selected by
the coordinator that knows nothing about
our protocol that includes the idea of
whether or not you are allowed to be a
leader so we have to read
to the acai after we have a litter
leader has to actually select the leader
so the way the leader selects the leader
is basically take all the identities
that are eligible to become a leader
sort them lexicographically and pick the
first one which means that if you have
you know a super powerful schema
registry host and you want it to always
become a leader
pick a host name like aaaa underscore
schema registry host and it will always
be the leader unless it's gone and then
basically the leader sends the same
assignment for everyone which is the
identity of the leader everyone compares
the identity of the leader to their own
identity if it's the same I'm the leader
not the same I now know who the who to
Ford they write request to whoa
fantastic I forgot to mention one
important part abstract coordinator
which I just explained how fun it is to
override is not actually a formal part
of the public API of Apache kafka which
means that theoretically we could change
it we did not change it in the last two
years but we could so if you want to
just do something like partition
assignment in a very smart way and not
try to override there some things that
may be slightly dangerous and you could
just implement your own assignor and it
turns out that this is what we did for
kafka streams and it turns out that you
can do actually a lot of logic by just
implementing the assignor logic so the
one thing these streams have to do is
join two streams of events and basically
the things that we want to do if you
have two topics and you need to join
them you want the same partition from
the same topic from two different topics
to end up talking to the same task
otherwise it couldn't really join them
and this task is going to have a state
it's going to have rocks to be the
season one machine and while we can
recreate these rocks to be from scratch
if we have to it's not a Harbison
stateful it costs time so we don't want
to if the rocks DB state already exists
we want to assign two partitions to a
task to a machine at the same time to do
our job which means that in order to
implement
the streaming as partition assignor the
metadata has to include information
about tasks about hosts about rocks
degrees and all kinds of fun stuff in
addition to the topical partitions that
everyone has we call this user metadata
which is an open loophole in the
partition assignment protocol so
basically the partition assignor
does a lot of work it validates that
both topics have an equal number of
partitions otherwise it will be really
hard to pair them correctly and we
validate that it groups the partitions
it creates the tasks that have to
process it
assign the tasks to consumers and to
hosts in order that based on the
availability of rocks DB and then it
sends back all this information in an
assignment like those are the partitions
those are tasks are active you run those
tasks with those partitions and here's a
mapping to this host if you're this
horse to run this stuff so this is
anything you can do it turns out that
the user metadata loophole era allows
you to do incredibly sophisticated stuff
without actually inventing your own
protocol and the last thing we may want
to do is assign tasks so cover connect
basically has the idea that you want to
click connect to database in such
reading data and you any connector could
have a lot of tasks that do it and we
have different worker processes and you
want to tell this worker to run those
tasks and the other worker to run the
other tasks this time our metadata is
how many tasks do we have what is the
configuration and should inch tasks
actually run or not so fairly simple the
leader in this case is just the leaders
of coordinator selected which is
absolutely fine
and it basically does a kind of slightly
modified round-robin you get this task
you get this task there's actually we do
it twice because we have two classes of
tasks lightweight and heavyweight but
that's the main idea
so to summarize Kafka has a pretty
generic coordination protocol and you
can use it to assign partitions in a
very nice generic way and you can cheat
with cool user metadata
and then you can also override the
entire coordinate assignment protocol to
actually assign things that are not
partitions at all that are leaders and
tasks and database partitions and
producers and all kinds of things that
are kind of unrelated so we really want
first of all I would love more people to
use it
I feel like doing leader elections that
way for example is often easier for me
to do then it would be in zookeeper if
you do definitely let me know drop me a
line or drop the Kafka user group a
developer group align we need to know
because if you use it we may decide to
make the API public so nobody else will
you know so we wouldn't change it
accidentally on you so we really have to
know if someone who is not us is using
it we have some future plans to use
things like generation ID there already
is a generation ID in the protocol so
you know if and if a real sign if the
assignment changes it has a different ID
you can use it to do all kinds of
fencing things which we currently don't
do but it would be nifty if we did it we
could do things like remember the
clients control what to do when they get
rebalancing progress so they can this
right now they basically stopped
consuming completely but if you know
that you're using something that is
sticky you could keep on processing
knowing that you're not going to lose
your partition so we can get a lot
smarter with that and then the last
thing right now it's everyone even if a
new consumer joins everyone rebalances
why I mean if we only move some
partitions from some members why should
we tell everyone the true balance is
going on and if everyone joined that's
kind of a big operation why not have an
incremental rebalance so those are all
things that we're looking to improve and
then if you want some reading material
for the flight back home you can have
you can read more about offsets you can
read a design that coordinates in the
broker which we decided not to implement
you can read everything that I basically
just said like the first half of the
talk in long written format and then
this is the example in the schema
registry if you want to go and see it's
really very
very few lines of code that give you
leader election because most of it is in
the obstructed coordinator
implementation do I have time for
questions how are we on time we have
three minutes right this would be like
one or two questions anyone has
questions
I totally overwhelmed everyone yes oh
the officer tensing we basically it's a
very well known pattern from relational
databases like we knew it from a oracle
redo logs and my sequel be logs
basically you have a sequence number I
think the big idea was applying it to
something that was at the time more or
less a pub/sub messaging system so yeah
and if you're interested in that topic
in general the book I love logs by J
Krebs is literally changed my life like
I read that and I'm like oh my god this
is brilliant and switched careers to
work on Kozma I'm not even slightly
exaggerating yes someone in the back yep
the group protocol does not maintain
consumer lag because offsets are kept on
a topic in Kafka but there is a bunch of
tools that will basically check the
topic periodically and tell you how far
behind consumers are a nice open source
one would be burrow a graphical name a
proprietary one would be the confluent
control center and you can basically
yeah I don't know and it's kind of easy
to write them yourself I mean there is a
documented format for how those things
get committed one last question
yes guy was a bird
[Music]
oh how big is it going to be so Kafka
limits
the request size and it's limited by
default to one megabyte which is way way
way too large and please don't ever get
anywhere near that and you may I mean if
you don't know that you have that maybe
drop it down to the reasonable 20k
limits but yeah I mean that's basically
the request size limit is the limits
that you're looking at I'm out of time
and I actually have to run to the
airport
I am a strudel Gwen sharp on Twitter and
I am incredibly happy to answer
questions on Twitter so you can go for
it
[Applause]